a warm welcome from a friendly Ally as
the Australian foreign and defense
ministers greeted the U.S defense
secretary and America's top Diplomat
particularly in challenging times it
makes such a huge difference to have
close friends close Partners as we
tackle uh the challenges that we both
face around the world and also try to
find some opportunity in finding finding
progress the two countries are united in
their vow to ensure stability and peace
across the indo-pacific region and
strengthen security cooperation
we want a region and a world which is
peaceful stable and prosperous and we
understand the importance of working
closely with you to ensure that that is
achieved so thank you so much for being
here that involves bolstering military
Partnerships in the indo-pacific to
counter China's increasing military and
economic power
30 000 troops are now engaged in two
weeks of War games in Australia in their
largest ever joint military exercise the
Pentagon says the increasingly regular
deployment of U.S forces in Australia
will expand the defense capabilities in
the region of both countries
in a show of strength Russian and
Chinese warships are holding joint Naval
drills in the Sea of Japan the Russian
defense Ministry says the exercises are
to help maintain peace and stability
the United States and Australia have
both called out China on what they've
described as dangerous and problematic
bullying Behavior
and I know that both of our countries
are concerned
about
attempts by the People's Republic of
China to depart from these principles
we've seen troubling PRC coercion from
the East China Sea to the South China
Sea
to right here in the Southwest Pacific
and will continue to support our allies
and partners as they defend themselves
from bullying Behavior as well as
Regional security climate change is also
on the agenda for talks on Saturday both
countries emphasizing the urgent need
for Action as well as the importance of
the transition to clean energy
any major announcement from these Osmond
talks is expected to be announced later
this year when Australia's prime
minister Anthony albanesi is expected to
join President Biden in Washington for a
formal State visit Sarah Clarke Al
Jazeera Brisbane